[Music]
[Applause]
to Michael Cole covers the Grizzlies
beat rider for the Memphis Commercial
Appeal he joins us now
uh update us on anything uh if you can
to Michael thanks for joining us
thank you for having me Dan but you
pretty much just stated some of the
latest there I think the main question
that people have had is uh is this the
NBA you know kind of assisting the
Grizzlies uh with this situation with
John Moran uh stepping away from the
team from what we know uh this is more
you know the Grizzlies decision to have
John rant step away from the from the
team and in regard to the NBA there's
still an ongoing investigation there
let's go back a year ago that you know
we could root for Memphis and it felt
like they were an Underdog Story uh
certainly you were getting highlights
from them and jaw every night and you
know we were rooting for them and him
and then all of a sudden I just I saw
them change as if they had been the
Golden State Warriors like they were
cocky you know they hadn't won anything
and I don't know if you noticed a change
in John Moran as well did this all just
happen with John the the last year and
nothing else attached to it
brighter lights than just just brighter
lights I mean you know covering the
Grizzlies over the past two seasons from
a personality perspective from ja and
the team uh this is who he's been this
is who the team been in terms of you
know playing with that you know that
flamboyant style you know that that that
confidence you know all the alley-oops
all of the you know the trash talking
they were trash talking everyone last
season the same way that they are this
season but last season they were The
Darlings right they were this up and
coming team wow they're not afraid of
the Warriors they're not afraid of this
team they're not afraid of Kevin Durant
but then this year it's like what are
these guys doing like why are they
talking so it's it's kind of a different
perspective of how people view the
Grizzlies but getting back to more in
the case of John Moran uh this is he he
kind of is a is a different type of
person than he in a way you know with
all the social media things that he does
he Prides himself on being one of the
few athletes this is something he said
he probably himself on being one of the
few athletes who will show you his real
life you know he he doesn't hide the
fact that he'll go out sometimes late at
night but guess what he'll let you know
that he's going to get up early that
next morning you know to get back in the
gym and things like that so this is this
is no secret you know uh to to us uh on
who he has been but it's more of the you
know the outside Antics and some of
those things kind of accumulating to the
point where now everyone's saying job
you know you have to take a step back
how did he get a gun in Denver
why did he have a gun in Denver
so from what we've heard there uh
there's been no you know confirmation on
whether it was his gun whether it was an
actual you know gun at all so uh that is
part of the NBA's ongoing investigation
from what I've been told that's one of
the things uh that you know is being you
know heavily looked at uh according to
you know the NBA rules uh the NBA rules
prohibits you know guns you know in
locker rooms on team planes and and
around team facilities so if that is the
case you know there could be some heavy
punishment coming along the lines but
again from what we've heard up to this
point there is no indication uh on if or
if it isn't you know a gun
are these is this all just a coincidence
that all this has happened with John or
with his guys this past year like
nothing else was happening off the court
with John Morant prior to a run-in at
the mall uh playing pickup with a kid at
his at his house uh you know his his
boys pointing a you know a laser uh
light or whatever at the Pacers I mean
this just this is new all this stuff is
just happening now
it again it goes back to those those
brighter lights for him right you know I
remember early on in his his career his
first couple Seasons right John Moran
you know it wasn't uncommon to see him
show his face you know around Memphis
you know and people would come tell me
hey look I saw John Moran at this place
I saw John ran at that place but he's he
has a little bit of a different light on
him now Dan and again that's where we go
back to he's 23 years old he has the
weight you know of of the Grizzlies
franchise on his show he is arguably you
know the biggest athlete to come through
you know the city of Memphis up to this
point and he's one of the faces of the
NBA he's one of the faces of Nike he is
the face of power raid you know at this
point and then there's Hulu body armor
so so much more at stake here so I think
what we're seeing is there are a lot of
warnings issued out Dan you know job be
careful job be careful and now it's to
the point he has so much more on the
line uh you're seeing you know these
situations where you know there's things
are being reported more on you know
intensively and things like that so uh
that's where we are right now and it's
it's simple you know yes he's only 23
and you know he's only been in the
league four years but John Moran has a
contract that could be worth more than
230 million dollars next season he has a
sneaker deal with Nike that will you
know a sneaker that debuts in April so
he has a lot to weigh here and that's
why all this heat is coming right now
because he simply has too much to gain
and a whole lot to lose what role does
his dad play he's he's always there uh
certainly at the home games yeah he's
there on the road too is his dad is is
there everywhere and was his dad in
Denver
I'm not sure if his dad was in Denver
but I mean he I will say earlier this
season you know he was there in Denver
he was in LA uh when they went on the
road early this season and pretty much
he goes to the majority of the away
games so the thing about his dad is they
have a great relationship as you know
most people uh can see and he does
challenge the job you know John will
tell you know anyone that his dad is his
biggest critic his dad is you know his
biggest hater sometimes and what I've
gathered you know just from talking to T
over the years you know he challenged
his job in in ways but you know
sometimes people question you know uh if
if T is you know saying some of the
right things to John and you know from
the conversations I've had with the
people around them uh T does seem like
he's you know telling job you know hey
you know you know what's at stake here
right now but you know John Moran again
he does have your mind of his own and
sometimes you know that seems to be the
case when you know he those things that
uh kind of fall back on into his hands
sometimes you got a big story on your
hands there Michael thank you for
joining us
appreciate you Dan no problem that's uh
to Michael Cole he covers the Grizzlies
a beat writer Memphis Commercial Appeal
well that'd be an interesting story if
Dad was in Denver with him